WOMAN WHO'S DESPERATE TO FIND
HER MOTHER WHO LIVES OUTSIDE
KYIV.
CLARISSA HAS THE DETAILS OF WHAT
SHE FOUND.
>> MY NAME IS ITALIA, I'M FROM
UKRAINE BUT THE LAST FIVE YEARS
I LIVED IN THE UNITED STATES.
MY MOTHER SHE IS STILL IN IRPIN.
>> AN IMPASSIONED PLEA SENT TO
US ON TWITTER BY A DAUGHTER
DESPERATELY TRYING TO TRACK DOWN
HER MOTHER.
>> MY MOTHER DOESN'T HAVE
CONNECTIONS.
I DIDN'T HEAR FROM HER A FEW
DAYS.
SHE IS BY HERSELF IN APARTMENT.
PLEASE, I BEG YOU, CLARISSA, YOU
ARE MY LAST HOPE.
>> Reporter: THAT MESSAGE
BROUGHT US BACK TO THIS SPOT,
THE DESTROYED BRIDGE WHERE BRAVE
VOLUNTEERS CONTINUE TO FERRY OUT
CIVILIANS WHO HAVE BEEN TRAPPED
IN IRPIN FOR MORE THAN TEN DAY.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THEY MAY BE ABLE
TO HELP FIND NATALIA'S MOTHER.
ON OUR WAY TO MEET THEM WE HEAR
A FAMILIAR ACCENT.
HE'S FLOWN HERE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO HELP IN ANY WAY HE
CAN.
LESS THAN A WEEK AFTER ARRIVING
HE IS EMBEDDED WITH UKRAINIAN
VOLUNTEERS AND NOW SPENDS HIS
DAYS HELPING IRPIN'S MOST
VULNERABLE ESCAPE.
>> WHEN I SAW THE INVASION I
BOUGHT A PLANE TICKET AND GOT
HERE AS QUICK AS I COULD.
THIS FEELS LIKE THE BIGGEST
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM I'VE EVER SEEN
IN MY LIFETIME.
>> Reporter: HAVE YOU EVER BEEN
IN A WAR ZONE BEFORE?
>> NOT LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: FOR MOST AMERICANS
THIS WOULD BE OUT OF THEIR
COMFORT ZONE.
>> IT IS OUT OF MY COMFORT ZONE.
YOU HEAR THE BOMBS AND AT THE
SAME TIME THERE'S PEOPLE A LOT
CLOSER TO IT THAN WRUS AND
THEY'RE REALLY THE ONES IN HARMS
WAY AND WE'RE JUST DOING OUR
PART TO GET THEM OUT OF HERE.
>> Reporter: DARIA AND HER TEAM
RISK THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY TO DO
JUST THAT.
SHE SPEEDS THROUGH DESERTED
STREETS LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE STRANDED AND NEEDS HELP.
SHE'S AGREED TO ADD NATALIA'S
MOTHER TO THE LIST.
SO DARIA, ARE YOU NOT AFRAID TO
DO THIS?
>> I AM AFRAID, OF COURSE.
I DON'T HAVE A CHILD YET AND I
UNDERSTAND I CAN HELP PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: THEY REACH THE
FIRST STOP.
SHELLING CAN BE HEARD IN THE
DISTANCE, AND THEY NEED TO MOVE
QUICKLY.
YOU CAN FEEL HOW THIS PLACE IS
COMPLETELY DESERTED.
IT'S LIKE A GHOST TOWN.
IS THE OWNER HERE, THEY SHOUT?
THE TEAM CONSULTS THEIR LIST TO
CHECK THE ADDRESS.
BUT NO ONE ANSWERS.
IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON.
IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS DARIA HAS
SEEN THE PLEASANT SUBURB OF KYIV
WHERE SHE LIVES TURNED INTO A
WAR ZONE.
DOES IT MAKE YOU ANGRY?
>> YEAH, I'M ANGRY.
AND I THINK IT'S OKAY.
I'M ANGRY TO ALL RUSSIAN
PEOPLE -- TO ALL THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE SILENCE IS ALSO
VIOLENCE NOW.
YOU ARE WITH UKRAINE OR WITH
RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: WE RECOGNIZE THE
NEXT STOP.
IT'S THE ADDRESS WE'VE BEEN
SEARCHING FOR, BUT THE FIRST
GLANCE IS TROUBLING.
SO THIS IS THE APARTMENT COMPLEX
WHERE NATALIA HAS TOLD US THAT
HER MOTHER LIVES.
I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
BECAUSE I CAN SEE THERE'S SOME
DAMAGE UP THERE PRESUMABLY FROM
ARTILLERY.
TEAM MEMBER ANTON ENTERS ONE OF
THE BUILDINGS.
WHO IS WAITING FOR EVACUATION,
HE SHOUTS.
BUT THERE IS NO REPLY.
NATALIA'S MOTHER IS NOWHERE TO
BE SEEN.
THERE IS JUST A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE STILL LIVING HERE.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND TELL US THEY
CHOP WOOD IN THE FOREST AND BURN
IT TO STAY WARM.
SO SHE'S SAYING THERE'S NO
WATER, NO GAS, NO ELECTRICITY.
THEY COOK THEIR MEALS OUT HERE
ON AN OPEN FIRE.
YET THEY REFUSE TO LEAVE.
WHERE WOULD WE GO?
WE DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE TO GO,
SHE SAYS.
WHETHER THEY KILL US HERE OR
THERE DOESN'T MATTER.
WHEN WILL THESE MONSTERS LEAVE?
ACROSS THE ROAD DARIA URGES
ANOTHER COUPLE TO EVACUATE, BUT
IT'S ANOTHER NO.
THEY'VE MADE IT THIS FAR AND
THEY'RE WILLING TO SEE IT
THROUGH.
THE TEAM HAS FOUND ONE MAN,
OLEG, WHO WANTS TO GET OUT.
HE BUCKLES INTO THE IMPROVISED
RESCUE VEHICLE.
BACK AT THE BRIDGE HE TELL
S US
ABOUT HIS ORDEAL.
IT WAS AN AWFUL, FRIGHTENING
SITUATION THERE, HE SAYS.
THEY SHELL US 224 HOURS A DAY.
THE REST OF HIS FAMILY IS NOW IN
A CITY HELD BY RUSSIAN FORCE IN
THE SOUTH.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I LIVE
ANYMORE, HE SAYS, BEFORE BIDDING
US GOOD-BYE.
IT'S TIME TO HEAD BACK.
OUR MISSION UNFULFILLED.
WE HAVEN'T FOUND NATALIA'S
MOTHER.
BUT AS WE GET CLOSER TO THE CITY
CENTER OUR CELLPHONE SIGNAL
RETURNS.
SO WE JUST HAD SOME GREAT NEWS
FROM NATALIA.
SHE TELLS ME THAT A FEW HOURS
AGO HER MOTHER WAS SUCCESSFULLY
EVACUATED FROM IRPIN BY ONE OF
TH